[Musique]
Émilie Nicolas Michel seoget Christian
Dufour bonsoir
on le savait là maintenant le principal
intéressé la confirmé je vous montre
comment sur les réseaux sociaux à
quelques minutes monsieur Lego annoncé
que dimanche tout ça allait partir
bonjour tout le monde j'ai le plaisir de
vous annoncer que la campagne électorale
va déclenchée officiellement le 28 août
prochain donc la campagne électorale
alors voilà
en fait vous pourriez me dire Émilie
Michel c'est et Christian qu'elle est
déjà déclenchée c'est un secret de
polichinelle que dans le fond
on va en parler dans un instant
d'ailleurs il y a des engagements très
précis Michel c'est og on le disait hier
c'est quand même un peu une usité là
c'est parti ça va être parti là
oui mais c'est inévitable les élections
on savait alors que lequel soit
déclenchée ce dimanche Ce samedi ou
c'est l'extrait de limite de toute façon
ça change pas grand chose ce qu'il
faudrait pour la prochaine fois penser
par exemple c'est est-ce que on devrait
pas avoir un mécanisme de limitation des
dépenses électorales ou pré-électorales
avant l'élection adaptix ça c'est une
autre débat puis il se fera après
élections parce que Christian et là
c'est des lutins parce que oui les
campagnes étaient lancées avant puis
bien sûr mais là c'est des annonces et
lutins des slogans tout est là c'est sûr
réaliste en fait de voir qu'on est en
train de commenter les promesses
électorales d'une campagne électorale
qui est quand même pas commencé
officiellement je trouve que c'est une
belle illustration en fait d'un projet
de réforme qui était très beau sur
papier le projet de loi des élections à
date fixes la part des gens était
d'accord avec ça sauf que ça a eu des
effets pervers majeurs auxquels les gens
n'avaient pas pensé donc c'est une
notion pour l'avenir je trouve qu'il va
vouloir la changer cette couleur là ça
marche pas on voulait améliorer le
système il y a quelqu'un qui mesure
aujourd'hui moi j'aimais le système
avant Émilie
mais c'est sûr que les inconvénients
avec les élections adaptées qu'il y
avait des gros inconvénients aussi avec
l'ancien système mais la question aussi
c'est ce qu'on peut régler certains de
ces inconviens là puis je pense que il y
a beaucoup d'observateurs en ce moment
qui sont d'accord sur le fait que si on
a encadrait mieux les dépenses
prélelectorales ça irait mieux il y a
aussi la réalité qu'on a un gouvernement
qui dépense en publicité des niveaux
records depuis bien avant sur l'été
dernière semaine aussi donc ça amène
aussi les parties de position à être
dans ça amène un cycle finalement de
dépenses où chacun essaie de mettre son
bout de l'avant donc il y a un ensemble
de pratiques qui sont peut-être
douteuses sur le planétique si elles
sont pas illégales en ce moment qu'il va
falloir observer mais ça reste que en
période estivale même si les gens font
une compétition pour faire des annonces
sur une grande partie des Québécois qui
sont encore à l'écoute aussi bon
très bien alors on a Monsieur Lego
aujourd'hui a décidé oui à Michel elle
excusez-moi
les inconvénients de laisser le Premier
ministre de sa guise de la date de
l'élection était infiniment plus on
prend discuter très longtemps Michel de
ça bon déjà c'est bien pas trop non
[Rires]
environnementale aujourd'hui de la part
de monsieur Legault un fond bleu pour
protéger rivière lac etc ou l'industrie
participerait beaucoup le gouvernement
aussi on écoute un extrait de Monsieur
Lebeau
j'ose dire que jamais un gouvernement au
Québec qui en a fait autant pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques puis
jusqu'à ce jour malgré les promesses de
certains bah il y a aucun parti
politique qu'un plan chiffré donc on
peut bien pelleter des nuages faire des
beaux discours mais il y a aucun parti
politique un plan chiffré pour réduire
les GES
ça c'était le message que Monsieur Lego
voulait lancer en début de campagne
Christian ils arrêtaient de Me
dépeindre comme quelqu'un qui n'aime pas
ou qui sous-estime les questions
environnementales et c'est ce qu'on
voulait envoyer comme message clairement
oui parce qu'il est sur la défensive
parce que c'est un secret pour originel
que ce sont pas les plus
environnementalistes de tous mais en
même temps son discours se tient quelque
part parce que ils profitent de la
situation très particulière du Québec au
Québec est quand même une partie
importante de la population les jeunes
souvent qui ont des convictions
environnementalistes ou la lutte au
changement climatique très forte ça peut
aller très loin mais le Québec de toute
façon il profite d'une énergie qui est
assez propre de l'énergie
hydroélectrique donc à ce moment-là on
peut lui pas tant que ça mais bon et
donc monsieur le groupe profite de sang
en disant bah il faut profiter de cette
situation là alors que d'autres gens qui
disent écoutez on s'occupe pas du bilan
objectif du Québec il faut vraiment
faire notre devoir de bons citoyens sous
les mondialisés qui veut sauver la
planète donc monsieur Lego dans ce
profil de cette situation là très
spécifique du Québec où il y a
l'idéologie des convictions d'une part
mais il y a une situation objective où
le Québec est favorisé parce que notre
bilan son compare au reste du Canada on
est vraiment très très bien placé même
sans faire trop d'efforts Émilie et
Michel c'est l'eau et ça revient dans
chaque campagne électorale qu'on protège
mulot qu'on demande des redevances plus
élevées etc donc là il touche un air
sensible Michel quand même
sensible mais en même temps et sans
raison on a beaucoup joué sur notre
vieux gagner essentiellement le bureau
électricité une décision qui a été prise
plusieurs à plusieurs décennies et c'est
ça qui nous donne un bon bilan notre
véritable problème actuellement c'est
pas mauvais ce qui propose là mais c'est
pas l'eau c'est de gaz à effet de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre c'est
là où on traîne la pâte c'est là où on
voit que même dans des situations
extrêmes comme la fonderie
à avoir des normes très sérieuses alors
c'est pas un mauvais mauvaise annonce
c'est une bonne chose mais il y a pas
une grande menace à l'eau au Québec
actuellement c'est pas là que le bob
blesse pour le bilan énergétique et
environnemental du Québec très bien
Emilie un petit mot là-dessus sur l'eau
d'abord et sur ce que a fait et a voulu
envoyer comme message monsieur Lego
aujourd'hui
je pense que
avec les quatre ans de mandats qui ont
déjà été effectué si les gens
sont convaincus ou pas convaincus de la
foi environnementale environnementaliste
de François degault c'est pas l'annonce
aujourd'hui qui va changer ça je pense
aussi que justement est en ligne c'est
un dossier sur laquelle il y a beaucoup
été critiqué je disais un peu plus tôt
que en période prélectorale comme ça
dans l'été il y a encore beaucoup de
gens qui portent pas attention à ce qui
se passe donc c'est une bonne chose pour
le gouvernement le goût d'annoncer
certaines mesures autant de faire
pendant que les gens écoutent pas trop
pour pour que ça soit faite
essentiellement que le point sauf sur la
table mais qu'on n'est pas non plus trop
de gens qui puissent répondre et
critiquer donc c'est pas que le plan en
soi et si pour en tant que ça c'est
l'ensemble des autres choses un peu
comme les autres analyses sur le le plan
environnemental qui sont difficile à
répondre donc autant commencer
maintenant pendant qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de gens qui écoutent puis
concentrer le vrai lancement de la
campagne sur des dossiers qui sont plus
dans les forces du gouvernement de
gauche comprend tout à fait la strat
vous êtes pas il vous laisse en
débarrasser mais presque là
on va écouter Gabriel ado Dubois et Paul
Saint-Pierre plat Mondon qui eux aussi
sont allés d'engagement à saveur
environnementale on voit le thème qui va
revenir évidemment comment faire
autrement on les écoute
les gens ils veulent faire leur part
pour la planète ils savent que les
changements climatiques c'est déjà
commencé mais si il y a pas
d'alternative ils sont impuissants nous
on va leur redonner des solutions des
options pour pouvoir faire dans leur
quotidien le choix écologique
vers les transports collectifs avec la
pince climat non seulement on fait des
économies sur une base individuelle donc
on a plus d'argent dans notre poche mais
on fait également des économies sur le
plan de l'État parce que c'est une façon
beaucoup plus intelligente de se
déplacer sur le plan des coups mais
évidemment la raison principale de cette
mesure-là c'est notre volonté de faire
face au changement climatique
rapidement sur cette proposition de Paul
Saint-Pierre flamandon 365 dollars une
passe
universelle pour prendre le transport en
commun un peu partout au Québec Michel C
c'est ingénieux
c'est une bonne idée le problème c'est
évidemment comme d'habitude dans la
réalisation vous savez si vous avez une
pince qui vous permet pour un dollar par
jour d'avoir tous les autobus du Québec
si vous êtes obligé de faire un
transfert puis que ça vous attendez 40
minutes pour l'autre autobus la Poste
qui marche pas alors il y a beaucoup de
travail à faire de coordination vous
avez vu comment ça a pris de temps pour
faire juste un changement de
tarification dans la région de Montréal
puis les gens ne comprennent pas encore
comment se fait que l'orgueil il y a pas
là-dedans etc ça c'est compliqué et
coordonner les autobus pour que et le
métro est tout ça pour que les gens
attendent de moins possible surtout en
région un peu plus éloigné ça c'est très
compliqué alors ça ça marche si on fait
l'autre c'est un prérequis que on a un
système intégré de transport on voit
qu'on cherche des façons originales pour
mousser encourager le transport en
commun et
c'est vraiment le Zap est vraiment dans
les détails sur une très bonne idée sur
le principe après c'est de regarder
est-ce que les gens qui prennent dans le
transport en commun quand on met des
prix abordables est-ce que c'est des
gens qui prenaient l'automobile avant ou
c'est des gens qui se déplaçaient des
gens transparent en commun ou c'est des
gens qui avaient d'autres types de
mobilité c'est des plans qu'on a vu dans
d'autres villes par exemple en Europe
aussi on voit seul ça a été des fois ça
crée un achalandage aussi un peu plus
grand qui permet justement d'augmenter
les horaires ce que ce à quoi Michel
faisait allusion donc c'est il faut
vraiment avoir plus de données concrètes
pour comprendre en fait qui est-ce qui
est ciblé par un programme comme ça si
c'est des gens qui se déplacent
rapidement souvent d'une région à
l'autre mais ces gens-là peuvent en
profiter mais est-ce que c'est un groupe
démographique et c'est important que ça
pour faire une différence sur les
changements climatiques donc il y a un
ensemble de questions à poser j'ai pas
j'ai pas les réponses
[Musique]
en promettant des choses comme ça ça
vaut beaucoup de crédibilité à vous et
moi le banquier on est on est pour cent
il prendra pas le pouvoir de toute façon
chaque je pense qu'on faut pas disserter
pendant une demi-heure là dessus oui
mais la campagne électorale même si les
parties ne prennent pas le pouvoir puis
le prochain dont je vous parlais il
serait étonnant qu'il prenne le pouvoir
monsieur duvet qui lui parle du
troisième lien si un sujet qui va faire
l'objet de beaucoup de débats et
l'aspect environnemental de la chose le
tunnel de voiture etc développement
urbain c'est le troisième lien et le
Parti conservateur du Québec j'ai déjà
mis à proposer un temps qui
remplacerait les pilons d'Hydro-Québec
donc remplacer le vieux pont pour l'île
d'Orléans en faire une partie vers le
sud
Michel
c’intéressant parce que le troisième
lien ça va cristalliser toutes les
différences des parties on va vouloir se
démarquer
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose de plus
cliva ou de plus patrimonial au Québec
l'île d'Orléans faire un pont sur l'île
d'Orléans ça va être qui vend c'était
évident il y aura des gens qui vont être
passionnément contre les résidents de
Lille probablement et peu de gens qui
vont être passionnésment pour
le problème est pas là le problème est
il faut penser le passage du fleuve à
Québec d'une autre façon est-ce que
c'est un tunnel il va coûter très très
cher les gens qui ont déjà dit qu'ils
vont être ils vont favoriser l'étalement
urbain est-ce que le médecin plus à
l'Est ça règle le problème je crois pas
il faut vraiment regarder
l'ensemble du dossier et pas le faire à
la pièce on ferait le troisième nez où
on fait pas le troisième mais ça c'est
mauvais
mais mais le débat ce rôle il va être
présent les gens devront se positionner
on ne peut plus évacuer cette question
là et ça dépasse la région de Québec
Christian oui mais moi je trouve une
tragédie franchement que ce qui devrait
être un grand projet collectif le fait
consensus fast objet de temps de
division le temps de chicane une chatte
hyper sexy plus je lis là-dessus là
c'est compliqué c'est pas normal Michel
a raison par exemple pour tuer à l'île
d'Orléans tu touches pas moi je veux
rester sur un point dont je trouve
personne parle moi j'ai vu que à Québec
25 ans c'est une ville que j'adore c'est
une des plus belles villes du monde je
veux dire l'aspect esthétique de tout ça
l'aspect patrimonial de tout ça sera
parlé un peu aussi on parle juste de
milliards puis de gros projets mais moi
je trouve c'est pas normal que c'est
encore que là là il y a des gens qui
voudrait que quelqu'un qui a un
référendum là-dessus la part des gens
ils connaissent on passe à cette
connaissance prendre une décision moi le
premier mais c'est devenu un
des choses une des choses qui qui est
vraiment compliqué dans le dossier
depuis le début c'est la question des
talmer urbain et de la façon dont ça
enquête sur des terres agricoles qui
sont qui sont dans la région c'est déjà
un problème pour la région de chasse si
on pense que ce soit un peu ou un tunnel
dans l'aile de Lévis mais avec la
proposition du Parti conservateur on
rajoute ce qu'elles sont là de la
banlieurisation de l'île d'Orléans qui
est pas quelque chose qui est souhaité
si j'ai bien compris par les gens de
l'île d'Orléans même donc on a même un
désavantage stratégiques alors qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens à Lili la Chambre de
commerce de Lévis appuyée par le masque
pousse pour le pont il y a même pas ça à
l'île d'Orléans donc je comprends pas
même politiquement l'intérêt de cette de
cette stratégie là sinon de regarder que
c'est peut-être que ça coûte moins cher
bon le Parti libéral du Québec
aujourd'hui il y avait aussi un
engagement madame anglais des revenus
sur
la sabre son engagement de donner un
médecin de famille par québécois 2000
infirmières praticiennes de plus
spécialisés d'ici 2030 mais le médecin
de famille de plus en fait d'accroître
le nombre de d'étudiants en médecine
on le voit alors on change de sujet la
santé ça s'arrête élection après
élection tour de table Christian je
commence avec vous la santé demeure un
enjeu important c'est vrai surtout après
la pandémie mais je dirais que la
crédibilité des promesses des partis
politiques étaient à peu près nulles
dans ce domaine-là parce que les gens
ont vu neiger bon quand on entend madame
Anglade nous il faudrait que tous les
Québécois un médecin de famille même
c'est merveilleux tout le monde veut ça
mais cette famille le tout le monde est
stressé parce que ceux qui ont pas de
médecins de famille risque d'être hors
du système mais quel crédibilité ces
politiciens-là ont-ils ça fait depuis 10
ans ça fait depuis 15 ans qui nous
disent ça puis la situation a toujours
malheureusement empirée donc je pense
que les gens veulent des résultats et
puis SMS en matière de santé dans le
cadre de la campagne électorale j'espère
qu'on va parler du français là c'est
bien beau tout le reste bien sûr qu'on
en parle pas qu'on laisse un mot pour
être franc on reviendra là dessus donc
la santé c'est méga important mais ce
qu'on veut c'est que le gouvernement
essaie de changer le système pour sa
s'améliore puis les gens ils croient pas
beaucoup moi le premier on attend les
résultats donc Madame anglais c'est bien
beau un médecin de famille pour chaque
Québécois on va applaudir le mot passe
un autre chapitre on va écouter madame
anglaise on vient en conclusion avec nos
deux amis
d'abord le nombre de médecins il va
falloir qu'on se dise qu'on n'a pas
suffisamment de médecins et qui va
falloir qu'on augmente ce nombre on va
augmenter de 1000 médecins
durant les cinq prochaines années
1000 médecins et ça ça va faire en sorte
que
les gens vont pouvoir au moins se dire
qu'il y aura la possibilité d'avoir
accès à la médecine famille
bon Émilie Michel c'est Michel c'est
d'abord
ça prend plus que ça forme un médecin
première des choses deuxièmement
Christian a raison là c'est comme le
petit garçon qui criait au loup un
moment donné plus personne n'a cru parce
que puis l'eau est arrivé un moment
donné cette affaire là moi je me
souviens à l'époque où marquival côté
ministre de la Santé disait pour réduire
le nombre de médecins le médecin il crée
sa propre demande et donc il faut pas
qu'il y en ait trop parce que ça va
coûter trop cher on a fait toutes les
codes figure et c'est pour ça que Madame
Anglade a peut-être raison que avoir
réussi à le faire moi je j'en doute
parce que tout autrement était essayé et
ne pas encore fonctionné Émilie
conclusions sur les médecins
conclusion de parler les médecins aussi
parler des infirmières puis en fait le
temps qu'on réglera pas le coq les
conditions de travail sont beaucoup plus
attractives dans le secteur privé les
gens il y a une hémorragie du personnel
de la santé vers le secteur privé puis
on s'appuie en plus de plus en plus sur
le secteur privé pour combler les trous
dans le secteur public c'est un cycle
dans laquelle on est dans ce montant
qu'on n'aurait pas réglé ça en fait
c'est sur cette question là moi que j'ai
envie que les partis politiques se
prononcent durant la campagne très bien
merci beaucoup ça se je rappelle donc
monsieur le Gaulle le confirmé on le
disait depuis un certain temps dimanche
matin déclenchement de cette campagne
électorale qui est déjà pas mal lancée
merci à vous trois bonne soirée à très
bientôt merci bonne soirée au revoir
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI